a lot of money marklar and i am live
from my exile
thank you all so much for joining me I
have not been able to scream thus far
during my exile as where I've been
signing has had no internet so not only
been signing 35,000 pictures of my own
ass but here I am in the final stretches
this is probably going to be the last
day another way to be signing because
everything in this room is the last
segment of these calendars as you can
see there's a lot of there's a lot of
counters here that pile of boxes over
there contains about probably because
I've been signing 35,000 of these bad
boys right here which are my very own
tasteful nudes calories as you can see
they wrap from June 2018 to no July 2018
to June 20 and they are chock full of
all sorts of wonderful delightful pieces
of art things of that nature
and things that you have seen and
stopped things that you may you probably
have seen this one but you definitely
haven't seen the wharfs - one the only
reason that I'm showing you now is
because people have started to get them
so people are posting pictures so I
thought I'd give you a guided tour of
Egypt if you have not seen yet so if you
ordered one of these they've started to
ship out they're not fully shipping out
because obviously I have 9,000 of them
right here but this chapter of my life
will finally be over after the day but
today is going to be a catalogue of my
own madness as we go through the various
stages of insanity as I finally finish
these goddamn calendars and sign up in
the best way that I can so without
further ado that's all
there and then I slap it right here I
individually inspect each one by the way
these tasteful nudes calendars are very
important because it's very important to
you so I make sure that each one of them
is perfect as they possibly can look at
them individually and then sign them
with mr. regular if some of these
signatures are messed up look I am only
human I've got one arm
sometimes when I'm signing I'm either in
a hurry there's an earthquake that
happens middle of it and my hand just
kind of falls off
I think signing on average about when I
was first starting out I was doing about
myself the person holding the camera is
Evan he's been helping me on organizing
these getting them prepped for me as I
go and then getting them packaged back
up as we go because it's the problem
with these calendars and the big reason
why I have to spend so much time in this
stuff is not because like it's hard to
sign no I mean the math works out if
each signature only took one second
across 35,000 calendars that's still 9.7
hours which isn't that long that's you
could do that in a day but each
signature doesn't take one second on
average the time actually sign move it
along
get to the next one it's around three to
four seconds and that's the fun of
booking it because not only that I have
to grab them I have to place them I have
to move them over there if my only job
is to just sign it's about three to four
seconds four seconds across 35,000
calendars is suddenly 38 hours now
that's not ideal either because it's not
four seconds per calendar no no no at
optimal speed it's about five to six
seconds and that's I never take a break
if I never slow down never take a break
never take to take it longer thanks why
it's taking over a week almost two weeks
now but not two weeks just units so I'm
gonna keep working the process is really
boring so I'm only gonna give you guys a
live
Hey once I have officially lost my mind
I want to talk to somebody and yeah I
just keep going on like this it's not
the problem boxes grabbing them
unpacking boxes and also interleaving
them because the calendars come [ __ ]
like this for ease of signing to save a
second or two per calendar they have
returned like that that may not seem
like a lot but I've already told one
second
across 35,000 calendars totals 9.7 hours
so even this is another nine point seven
dollars hence the help and hence why I'm
losing my mind
today I'm gonna be signing around 9,000
I managed to get done at the factory
with about 6,000 left to go and I did
that six thousand made out seven hours
so I should be in good shape to finish
these today but my hand was about to
explode so thank you everybody so much
for watching
remember it's not hires it's an exile
and it's an exile for you I don't do
this for me you think I put some ego
trip from signing pictures of my own
naked but no I mean yes but not I did
pleasure and satisfaction from knowing
that each and every one of you is going
to get a hand side signature from me to
you and you know what I'm gonna draw a
little extra on here like love mark
whoever gets this you're special
and each and every wonderful is special
but this person will be
so take care guys a bye bye yeah are you
sure you want the string stuff